[Ukraїner
Експедиція]
Менше тексту, більше дій!
Поїхали! Витягаймо човники!
[Бессарабія,
Сергіївка]
[тріскочуть на вітру вітрила]
Хутчіш! Наступний човен заходить.
Підіймаймо ніс!
Микито, ти допомагатимеш?
Підіймаймо. Допомагай.
Підіймаймо ніс! Підіймаймо!
Саньок, допомагай! Допомагай із човном!
Давай-давай-давай!
Мені було 8 рочків, майже 50 років тому,
і я почав займатися
вітрильним спортом.
[В'ячеслав Сметанка
Засновник школи з вітрильного спорту]
А потім запросив
свого молодшого брата.
Потім ми зробили школу в Сергіївці.
Вона стала потужною.
На цьому місці, де ми зараз
сидимо,
тут така гарненька бесідочка,
ось тут було болото.
Але ми собі розробили план.
Тут небагато людей: у мене
є компаньйон, брат, мої учні.
І ми крок за кроком, крок за кроком —
і тут уже можна посидіти.
Ось там стоїть маленький корабель.
Так на цьому лимані не було
де скинути такий катер.
Тут у Сергіївці була друга база,
але вона була маленька.
Я поставив собі за мету зробити таку
базу, яка зможе бути потужною.
Приймати великі змагання.
Щоби приїжджало багато людей.
Щоби сюди приїжджали,
зокрема, з-за кордону.
Цьому проєкту 10 років.
І він іде за свій кошт.
Дуже тяжко.
Ми все робимо самі.
Матвію, треба йому допомогти.
Помагай, помагай!
Лицем!
Поворот!
Поворот.
Я вже двічі сказав «поворот».
Ті поїхали на Чемпіонат Європи,
ті поїхали ще кудись.
Діти дивляться на це —
ті поїхали, і я хочу.
Подивитися на світ, щось
поїсти, попити — діти...
Вітрильний спорт — це не просто спорт,
там багато чого треба знати.
Дуже багато.
Тільки у нас ось такенної
товщини книжка правил змагань.
Їх усі потрібно вивчити.
Ось цей спорт одразу
дає широку освіту.
Коли дитина її отримує, то вона
легко керуватиме автомобілем.
Дитина швидко рухається,
мало хворіє.
Над водою нема тих
мікробів, що є в місті.
Це чисте повітря.
Ось це — степс, ось тут унизу.
Степс, він прикручується і
туди вставляється щогла,
щоби вона не хиталася,
не звертала туди-сюди.
Це — шверх, його вставляють для того,
щоби не зносило й не дрейфувало.
І ось так не перевертало.
Перо для того, щоби повертати.
Але можна повертати
навіть вітрилом. Без пера.
Ми будемо виходити на море!
Ось там у нас є коса...
Ми будемо з лиману...
Вибачте, будь ласка, не...
Не перебивай! Слухай, ти
розказав свою частину,
тепер дайте мені
розказати свою.
Дякую.
Це не сценарій!
Це не по сценарію.
Там є така коса...
О, дрон!
Там є така коса,
і за косою Чорне море.
Ми зараз туди попливемо на «Оптимістах»...
Підемо!
Підемо.
І там десь причалимо,
вийдемо покупаємося.
Якщо хочете, можете з нами.
Ті, хто досяг потужних
результатів у спорті,
у нас є.
Мені є чим пишатись.
Спорт — це така справа,
що потрібно бути тільки першим,
тільки найкращим.
А яхтинг — це навчитися чогось,
навчитися справи з вітрилом.
Це, я думаю, навіть краще.
Мій друг із Києва, Ігор Леончук,
то ми з ним займаємося практикою навчання
управління вітрильним човном,
оздоровленням і відпочинком.
Попраляй!
Зрозумів.
І піднімай. Давай.
Відкренюй веселіше човен!
Так! Вивішуй дупу за борт!
Вивішуй за борт!
Так, поворот оверштаг!
Пішов!
Потужніше!
Добре!
Ми сьогодні працюємо над
цими поворотами оверштаг,
[Ігор Леончук
Тренер з вітрильного спорту]
які у нас кілька днів не виходять.
Пішов! Поворот!
Давай!
Дивимось: ось він зараз перейшов,
йому потрібно перестрибнути,
спіймати вітер на іншому галсі,
пересісти й поміняти руки.
Молодець! Уже краще!
Ще раз, сміливіше!
Так, Сашо, трохи ближче до
носа сядь — вітер слабкий,
всередину яхти сядь!
Всередину!
Рома, увага!
Зроби нам як належить
гарний поворот оверштаг!
Оверштаг, Ромо!
В інший бік кермо, ти що!
Бачите, ще все плутає.
Молодець Рома!
Ми розуміємо, що Чорного моря
та узбережжя у нас стало поменше.
Але Сергіївка саме для вітрил буде,
скажімо, найкращою меккою.
І кожного року, з кожним роком
я спостерігаю, що іде розвиток,
іде рух.
З таких міст як Сергіївка, — з курортних
міст, — люди не повинні виїжджати.
У нас тут є гаряча вода,
у нас цілющі грязі, у нас багато риби.
У нас усе є.
Заробити би фінансовий інструмент,
ми би зрушили з місця.
Думаю, за рік я би тут
просто красу зробив.
Красу!
І сюди би приїжджали
вже тисячі людей, бо...
В очерет ніхто ж не хоче лізти.
Ні, хочуть — он там
пташки цвірінькають трохи.
Вперше тут з'явилися
пелікани років 6 назад,
і вже тут загніздилися.
Ті, котрі прилітають сюди —
це ті птахи, що тут народилися,
вони обрали за Батьківщину собі Україну.
Треба тут щось робити.
Нічим ця вода не гірша, ніж...
Пеліканам же подобається.
Вони ж сюди прилітають.
Додому.
[Автор проєкту
Богдан Логвиненко]
[Оператори
Павло Пашко, Андрій Рогозін]
[Продюсерка
Оля Шор]
[Режисер
Микола Носок]
[Монтажер
Андрій Рогозін]
[Музика
Endless Melancholy]
[Ukraїner
Експедиція]